if you call yourself a motion designer
then you need to know how to design a
top-level motion designer is an animator
and a designer hi there my name is
Cameron and I am a motion designer with
over 15 years of pro experience I
created the course main titles American
soldier to show you the exact processes
used to design main titles for film and
television in this training course we
begin by diving into the pre design
process we walk through the creative
brief use Pinterest to explore reference
and inspiration take a look at Adobe
Typekit for type exploration and talk
about getting design inspired through
music plus we use the power of Creative
Commons to pull together free assets
used in designing the frame next we will
move on to the main design process and
walk through designing each of the nine
style frames we cover layering and
texturing technique typography matte
effects and so much more we also explore
the process of designing in After
Effects and finally we will move through
the crucial last step in style frame
design adding that final layer of polish
now you can learn the secrets to become
a badass main title designer sign up
today and let's get started